[Música]
y hablamos de salud en directo américa
de france 24 ya está conmigo lista más
romeros a la para ponernos entonces n
cintura sobre estos temas de salud
empezamos con los nuevos hallazgos sobre
el ela una enfermedad neurodegenerativa
marque información tenemos pues es una
información que viene desde madrid en
este caso desde el instituto de
investigación es oftalmológicas ramón
castroviejo de la universidad
complutense de madrid- y básicamente lo
que dice es que esta enfermedad conocida
como ela que es la esclerosis lateral
amiotrófica también provoca cambios en
la retina del ojo pudimos hablar con la
doctora pilar rojas ella es la principal
investigadora de este estudio y nos
contó cuáles pueden ser los impactos de
estos nuevos hallazgos escuchemos la
es una ventana abierta al sistema
nervioso central dado que nos permite
visualizar de manera directa y a través
de la pupila la retina que forma parte
del sistema nervioso central junto al
cerebro y la médula espinal lo que se ha
visto en este estudio es que los cambios
que ocurren en la microglía y las
neuronas en la médula espinal y en el
cerebro de los pacientes con ella'
también se ven en la retina y esto
abriría la puerta a poder monitorizar a
estos pacientes y poder monitorizar las
terapias de estos pacientes de una forma
menos invasiva es más fácil y por
supuesto menos costosa se sabía que esto
ocurría con pared y de manera parecida
por ejemplo con el alzheimer o con el
parkinson que también modificaban la
retina precisamente por formar parte
también del sistema nervioso central
pero ahora pues se sabe que también
ocurre con el el ahí también que
mecanismos lo provocan y esquel el a
básicamente lo que afecta es el tejido
nervioso las neuronas motoras eso afecta
a la movilidad de los pacientes que se
enferman y eso pues muchas veces se ha
robado el protagonismo de esta
enfermedad no es esa falta de movilidad
pero lo que ahora sabemos es que también
afecta a los nervios motores del ojo
esas funciones motoras del ojo por esas
microglías que explicaba la doctora que
son como unas células que defienden el
sistema nervioso y también porque mata
las células de las neuronas perdón
ganglionares que es un tipo de neurona
que transmite la información visual el
ojo al cerebro y que forma el nervio
óptico esto como comentábamos abre la
puerta a nuevos nuevos diagnósticos no a
tratamientos no para curar la enfermedad
pero sí pues para tener maneras menos
invasivas de descubrir cómo está la
enfermedad de diagnosticar la enfermedad
aunque la doctora nos dejó dicho que
digamos que esos hallazgos son sólo el
primer paso y que hace falta todavía
mucha más investigación seguimos en la
carrera investigativa sobre esta
enfermedad marc pero hablamos ahora de
la ema la agencia europea del
medicamento que publicó unos datos sobre
la seguridad de las vacunas contra el
kobe 19 exactamente lo principal
básicamente es que siguen diciendo que
no tienen datos suficientes para
establecer un vínculo entre la
miocarditis las inflamaciones de corazón
y ninguna vacuna contra el cubit 19
millón son en johnson ni moderna ni
facer ni astrazéneca no está esta
declaración llega precisamente pocos
días después de que algunos de los
organismos asesores científicos de
gobiernos por ejemplo en alemania y en
francia recomendaron que para los
menores de 30 años se aplicará
únicamente la vacuna de facer no la
vacuna de modernas precisamente por esas
esos casos de inflamaciones de corazón
hemos traído algunos datos publicados en
alemania precisamente por el instituto
paul el ritz que hablan de esas
diferencias y de esos casos y es que
tras la vacuna de moderna se detectaron
11 7 casos de inflamación del corazón
por cada 100.000 dosis versus 468
énfasis en las mujeres la proporción es
mucho menor pero sigue siendo más
elevada también en el caso de modernas
que en el caso de facer todo esto para
menores de 30 años la agencia europea
del medicamento dice que sigue revisando
estos datos y sobre todo instó a las
farmacéuticas para que hagan estudios
específicamente sobre esto para seguir
acumulando información pero bueno hasta
ahora esto es lo que tenemos y todo
tocará a ver qué dicen los entonces
reguladores que al final es quienes nos
orientan en todo es así es más veo
moderna y todavía me recuerdo los los
estragos que sufría mi cuerpo a causa de
la vacuna pero bueno mañana se conmemora
el internacional de la lucha contra la
neumonía marc impacto tiene esta
enfermedad es un impacto bastante grande
y además es una enfermedad que muchas
veces asociamos a personas mayores no
pero en es la enfermedad infecciosa que
más muertes genera en todo el mundo en
niños y niñas menores de 5 años en 2020
se cubrió la vida de hasta 800 mil niños
en ese rango de edad que es el 15 por
ciento de las defunciones en total para
conmemorar ese día traemos una buena y
una mala noticia la buena es que desde
2020 la mortalidad por esta enfermedad
se ha reducido un
47% la mala es que a día de hoy todavía
hay un 40% de niños que se enferman de
neumonía que no reciben tratamiento
adecuado eso significa que si recibieran
ese tratamiento adecuado si llegara todo
el mundo probablemente esa reducción de
mortalidad sería todavía mayor raúl y se
publicó un nuevo estudio que relaciona
el aceite de palma con el cáncer que
sabemos sobre esto pues está llega desde
barcelona- desde una investigación del
institut biomédica guerra cerca de
barcelona precisamente identifica que
este ácido palmítico que es el principal
componente del aceite de palma favorece
que los cánceres causen metástasis que
se extiendan por todo el cuerpo se
publicó en la revista han hecho
escuchemos que decía esa publicación
aquí mostramos que el ácido palmítico
pero no el ácido oleico ni el ácido
linoleico promueve la metástasis en
carcinomas orales y melanomas en ratones
tumores de ratones que recibieron una
dieta rica en aceite de palma a corto
plazo o células tumorales expuestas
brevemente al aceite de palma in vitro
siguieron siendo altamente metastásicas
incluso después de eliminar la
exposición al aceite
sé que es un poco enredado todo esto que
está sobrando pero ya lo vamos a
traducir valores antes de esto aquí
claro ese es el trabajo que estamos
haciendo lo que dicen es que una dieta
rica en este aceite de palma que tiene
ese ácido palmítico que está nombrando
el estudio empuja a las células de los
tumores que ya existen a desarrollarse a
extenderse por todo el cuerpo y que eso
se mantiene incluso si esa dieta deja de
mantenerse no cuando dejan de exponerse
se sigue manteniendo esto en cambio no
ocurre por ejemplo eso también es
importante tenerlo en cuenta con el
ácido oleico que es por ejemplo los
aceites grasos del omega 9 por ejemplo
el aceite de oliva sin ir más lejos ni
tampoco pasa con ese ácido que estábamos
diciendo que se llama nylon linoleico
perdón que es el omega 6 por ejemplo que
se encuentra en el aceite de soya en
aceite de girasol estos dos alimentos no
entran no provocan lo mismo que este
aceite de palma se sabía que podría
tener algunos efectos pero ahora además
se conocen esos mecanismos concretos y
eso como siempre abre la puerta a nuevos
tratamientos para contrarrestar estos
efectos nocivos marc y hasta mañana que
nos vemos con más salud